götze et aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
la bêta de 9 heures c'est un survival
horror vous savez que je suis très fort
à ce genre de jeu a jamais joué je
découvre avec vous on va créer d'autres
persos d'accord donc chicken days qui
achètent ces attitudes la place sur la
planète
moi j'ai envie de faire pharrell
williams va faire pharrell williams mais
en blanc avec un bruce timm négatif
ok comme ça c'est bon t'as farrell
excusez moi c'est moi on a farrell
ça marche avec les attitudes c'est
génial oda phares ailes hayon banon
quand même venu à paraître dans une zone
sûre où quelque part sur la planète a
peut-être apparaître aux yeux ou
védiques arié on le gagne on à paris on
veut alors on a juste un couteau de
cuisine et un bébé un peu glauque voilà
bon ça lui aussi mignons ils étaient en
train de se faire un couteau avant de
mourir
oh [ __ ] j'ai vu de la fumée quand mon
gars tu as pourquoi j'ai spawn dans
l'ordre je sais pas où ils sur cette
table j'aurais dû aller dans la zone sur
la commune aux conseillers et ne voit
pas nous sommes invisibles abattage
attendait mais l'avion va l'affronter un
moment il va arriver mais dans l'app la
maison mais je suppose que pageau basket
basket
do you know what is basket non do you
know what is better than life
ces marqueurs madrid mon écran nous
détenons isat peaches come here you you
[ __ ] mais l'envié maison il ya fait
ses petits frères d'après ses frères
ouais on l'a vu oui qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui se passe à grands
frais aussi bien toute la famille
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ok on va courir va courir m'a décidée au
plat de côtes et le grillage ah bah non
mais c'est et les ports ok j'ai plus
d'endurance et voilà c'est le problème
un double interface mattingly ebolowa
qu'est ce qui se passe va zy ok vous
êtes mort on a tenu une minute
bon ça peut d'y aller au tableau ni s'il
vous plaît oh non on doit recréer un
autre caractère
ça suffit voulez-vous apparaît dans une
posture où n'importe où dans le monde la
zone sûre s'il vous plaît j'ai
absolument 0 idée de hoya dès janvier au
ces deux alliés bonjour québec et moi
aussi je vais apprendre un slide est
comme toi s'il te plaît lp comment je
lui parle
aïe you can't take me home et robinho ac
devrait être au chevet wes helms mission
ok vous tu peux pas dire regardez le lui
aussi des marchandises non c'est à moi c
est qu est le boss crémone
yes on suit crédit non sucré nîmes non
c'est un mec qui va nous tuer il va vous
tuer direct hassidou dessus vers plus de
la sln
on peut situer là avec lui j'ai dit
viens avec moi je suis un pro mais pas
du tout on fait quoi
viens au ils veulent nous tuer
traître il va nous tuer pourquoi tu as
pu faire ça 1 pourquoi
mais quel gros lâche aux phoques
bon ben on sait ce qu'ils jettent dessus
pic scandaleux un bandage where can we
go wouah au nom au nom il m'a trahi très
bien donc je voilà la mentalité ça
marche pas de problème
ok j'ai compris why did you do that i'm
a rendu mon sniper il est mignon mais il
a pris le shotgun bien évidemment
d'accord elle donne un sniper s'emballe
mais plus tard à une troll brazy enfin
l' aventure là allez c'est bon j'ai
quitté la safe zone
apparemment ça se voit non faut que
j'avais auteurs il n'a pas à la hauteur
ok s'en foutent de la hauteur [ __ ]
mesquita scelzo je me fais agresser
direct quoi de manière instantanée en
liesse on a trouvé plein de trucs là
ocha c'est bon on est les chevaliers là
on va l'appeler rabbit
voilà ça veut dire n'a pas en anglais ce
qui n'est pas du tout logique qu'y at-il
dans l'autre immeuble juste en face rien
à part des poubelles
on va pas faire les poubelles quand même
bordel j'suis sûr comparé dans la
poubelle yes qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
un fusil à pompe obligé dans les
poubelles au lit avec la bien mais
cadeaux wasquehal chauvel buts et 11 kg
à la poubelle pourquoi je peux pas le
mettre à puisque c'est une pièce d'art
caisse pas toutes d'accord ok bon et pas
des poubelles à faire là [ __ ] c'est la
preuve fois de ma vie que j'aime faire
les poubelles
pourquoi je leur donne tuer mais [ __ ]
je l'aï refait bordel de merde chose à
faire mais poubelle comme un vieux gars
non je cachais dans la foulée il me
retrouvera jamais on sait qu'on est bien
caché il est où il est caché il est là
où vous regardez le il est tout en haut
aux [ __ ] non elle va pas être autre
côté soit possible à aa mais non mais
pourquoi le mec sur le toit et tirent
dessus il pouvait pas m'aider bordel de
merde et je l'attends ici j'attends ici
je défonce fois au pro bowl c'est pas
prévu que rue tient au caire mais ok
d'accord donc là il ya toute la famille
le papa le frère et la petite soeur qui
apprend à chasser mais elle a vu sauter
tard ok donc là c'est carrément le grand
père non je me suis enfermé futur est
tout sauf toi bien sûr se moque de moi
là non mais là les attend mais gégé à
paris où là ok ça marche d'accord donc à
personne à cent mètres autour de moi
c'est génial on va prendre la prochaine
à gauche sur bad street qu'il ya complot
[ __ ] y'a plein de choses ici c'est sûr
dans les tentes non red recyclables sur
ce squelette non plus par contre dans un
sac de couchage ray beaucoup de choses
j'avais pas d'examiner [ __ ] elle examine
de ouf la examen complet
du truc alors vous avez danger de
monsieur avec une légère gastro [ __ ]
mais c'est naouel d'examiner o o o o ce
cachot ce cachot se cache au stage non
non au départ je me suis enfermé avec un
vous a retiré tout à fait tard et voilà
c'est fini
non ça j'en ai marre de décéder au lac
et à la haye
d'accord oui je viens danser avec toi je
sais ce que tu veux faire
tu me demandes d or de la saison pour
mettre une balle dans le crâne ça doit
passer au moins neuf rangs pas moins qu
elle est bien bonne or what
et ça c'est notre arme [ __ ] ça fait
trop les d'accord et on recherche comme
ça on doit aller ici ok il fait nuit
noire c'est parfait c'est le pire moment
du monde pour sortir de là s'est il faut
mais tu me dis pas ce que je dois faire
vienne flèche il ya des coups de feu
[ __ ] et bon vieux coup de feu des
familles au on dire dessus
cette attention je suis armé très
dangereusement je tiens à préciser je
fabrique et ce pistolet avec un peu de
colle du scotch et du bois les
redoutables ne sous-estimez jamais ok on
peut viser d'accord ce qui est génial
c'est que c'est à peine approximatif
bonjour alors sois là sur le poteau sur
le but le bâtiment je ne sais pas
yes ok faut qu'on aille au musée machin
c'est là en plus au km reste 100 points
de vie vim
mais non mais pourquoi tu jamais rien
sur moi mon gars tu as même pas de quoi
opérer des dents de ton fils avec sa
williams et l'eau il ne prend même pas
il fait assez nul au [ __ ] mais voilà
j'ai tué pour rien
je montrerai un monde sait de quoi je
suis capable ok ok ok c'est bon j'ai
compris j'ai compris ce code j'ai
compris scott basse et papaye maison
mais on meurt pas mal de fois j'ai bien
il est l'heure de changer de serveur la
transition amène à aa
ah non aller au bazooka bazooka sa marge
des cigarettes
on entendait sur toi d'en face ok c'est
parti mon dieu oh c'est tellement
intense a annoncé le mur à la nullité
mon père c'est bien fou stop stop ça
suffit
cours petit gros montant jamais enfilé
capacitif s'il vous plaît non go ya quoi
sur son écran pour qu'elle ne souffre
d'être pareil tu fais quoi mon gars
regardez-moi les partis en courant on
lâche tient beach il n'aura pas des
hindous et bas n'ont jamais anticipé mon
gars alors on peut ramasser des choses
qui nous ont lâchés aucune idée alors là
on a ramassé par exemple une chaudière
tour gct squeeze m.gross pourquoi avez
vous ramassez ce truc je n'en sais rien
je propose de le relâcher de le taper et
de m'asseoir dessus voilà au aux [ __ ]
le fourbe
je vais à monter sur le bus pour
m'enfuir ah ouais ouais ouais je suis
monté sur le plus beau gage même pas lu
les witches tu fais plus il a répondu ce
pauvre bus
[Musique]
on va mener george c'est à dire fin de
cette petite vidéo sur nether fois j'ai
quand même joué deux heures c'est pas
rien on peut en conclure que je suis
d'une extrême du lit questionné sur
michael offer j'espère ça vous aura plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas mais la
vidéo ça fera vraiment plaisir et je
pense que vraiment on doit qui fait ce
jeu quand on joue avec des potes quand
on chasse les monstres avec des potes
fin qu'on évolue tout simplement avec
des avec des potes chat le monde en
piste
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]